so waste a money dog what I don't even
understand how that's even in the horror
genre die I miss the least scared I've
ever been man it's like like a romantic
comedy my lullaby dog yeah for reals dog
oh oh where you that Ohana
where are you punking but yeah I'm over
that way boy
are you alway down there yeah well I'm
this way to it oh hi duck
no what was it I walk you to your car
like words bribe you back to your car a
demon could possess any inanimate object
that's too general to be scary
how you gonna have a demon post it up in
a trash can it's unrealistic is what it
is like I ain't gonna be scared of no
trash can any what was that other thing
to have with the the the demon puddle
yeah yeah that was the most stupid pot
right there a demon can pull you in the
Hale if you step in a puddle like we
some moron I mean how you gonna scare a
couple of dos with a plug stop it stupid
demon got the hellhounds roaming around
everywhere bringing humans to the demon
alive to be Sapir
you know it's like it's lazy stories yes
yes is what it is it's a lot of things
but scary is not one of them
[Music]
yeah I'm sorry dog you tried to
watch that dumbass
[Music]